ليس الصربيا وحدها انما العديد من الدول
في اوروبا الشرقيه الان تسعى للانضمام
للاتحاد الاوروبي على راسها اوكرانيا في
هذه المشاريع هل ستكون في صالح الاتحاد
الاوروبي ام انها ستضعف الاتحاد الاوروبي
بحيث يكون الاتحاد الاوروبي
مجبر على على الدخول في حرب حقيقيه في حال
تعرض اي منها لاي عدوان
لست متاكدا
ولكن لا اعتقد بان هذا سيضعف الاتحاد
الاوروبي
[موسيقى]
كما سمعنا اوكرانيا هي الدوله اكثر قوه
ومتحده ما توقعها الكثيرون كما انها اكثر
كفاءه على الصعيد العسكري
او لا شك بانها ستعتبر من الاصول المفيده
للاتحاد الاوروبي
ولكننا لا نعرف الى اين تتجه الامور او
كيف ستنتهي من الممكن ان
ينتصر الطرف على الاخر
ويحققون اصلا حاسما ولكن على الارجح بان
الحرب ستنتهي
باتفاق غير مورد
يتركه على السياده غير محدده في مناطق
معينه
ويتركوه كل طرف يسيطر على اراضي يطالب بها
الطرف الاخر لذلك سيكون تحديا صعبا على
مدى سنوات القادمه
ولكن يبدو ان هنالك
مصاحف مصالح كثيره في اعادتي بناء
اوكرانيا
وستكون هنالك حزمه كريمه جدا
لاعاده بناء اوكرانيا بعد ان تنتهي الحرب
حتى وان انتهت باتفاق مؤقت اوقف اطلاق
النار وليس عبر التسويه
وهذا سيمنح الاوروبيين
الشيء اضافي لتوحيدهم ليعملوا عليه معا
وهو اعاده بناء اوكرانيا